this video was brought to you by loot
crate welcome to fine dining with
PewDiePie the first course please
the first meal is proper endo it's a
Mexican candy I'm very excited move
I think this is year 1902 extra hot and
salted we have something some fine wine
water to rinse it down the taste
let's see yeah it's no way what I see
thank you this is impossible
Oh delicate delicate delicate smell
Oh
I didn't expect that one to actually be
disgusting people eat this it's really
good
whole Parinda why would anyone eat this
next meal please try retails beer candy
not sure how to all right let's give it
a taste
feel a little frisky
from this beer Oh head guy you want some
let's do bad you're underage you can't
drink until you're my age
next meal chef
ah Miguelito
I got my dungeon key trade can spice
next chef next course please
are you kidding me
chilli Chaplin is my favorite how did
you know chef grasshoppers can't wait
there's no [ __ ] way it's not going on
there they are so hard for the muse
let's bring it yeah oh goody bag thank
you
thank you sponsored chef all right
listen up fellow gentleman's loot crate
is a monthly subscription box this is
December steam which is galaxy oh boy
let's have a look inside shall we don't
you just love getting a box every month
that's loot crate for you baby
with new items for you every time they
change your theme the 19 each month a
t-shirt oh [ __ ] what is this this looks
legit okay we got a strange box you
can't eat it but I'll open it oh I could
so lower my critters in here and a
little snacks if I get hungry on the
road but wait there's a han Solo pop
there yet I love these I see you over
there getting jealous that's okay whoo a
Galaxy Quest genes mark I'm gonna put
this right between the butt cheeks so
everyone will know where the galaxy is
Oh Star Wars sucks
with bb-8 that's pretty cool that's
pretty cool very soft
like a mother such but wait would you
like to know more all right some some
hallo stuff I don't supply req pack from
Halo 5 do you want my code I read it out
mw2 Q now this is the important part to
support the show if you check out loot
crate and get awesome items like this
every month it's almost like you have a
friend who cares every month check out
loot crate calm / parrots next one theme
is going to be invasion go to loot crate
calm slash payloads into the code
pillage
you get 10% off on the loot crate oh and
it supports the show and we can keep
doing this stupid [ __ ] where's the food
where's the damn foot finally you know
how to surprise me chef you know what I
like
mix critters we're gonna we got the tiny
little maggots
we got the bigger crickets the buffalo
worms the mealworms these these things
will live inside you oh and oh boy oh
boy do we have the locusts which like a
fine cigar I don't want to eat this one
there's that cornflakes I'm not even
kidding this is like Rice Krispies do
you know and then yeah
right
they're not bad I'm not kidding big spin
me all the wings you feeling their wings
they hit somebody thoughts in my head
right now
this is like a jump before jumping off a
cliff little bit
ah
[ __ ] me I haven't seen it close before
Alex or disgusting oh god don't look at
it [ __ ] terrible oh boy skin ah oh
boy oh boy oh boy what a fine dining
experience this has been thank you for
welcoming into your home I hope that we
can share this experience with you and
meet again for Tudor space Thank You
Luke rave for sponsoring this video
remember to check out Luke's great calm
such pills
enter the code pills do it give it a try
live life on the edge
and that's it for me for now leave a
like we enjoyed watching this video and
I'll see you in the next video